the Joe Rogan experience my friend and
colleague Roy Baumeister wrote that
great book on evil in which he actually
went and interviewed serial killers and
rapists in prison and said you know
why'd you do it and you know he
discovered that they all had this
perspective like well this is why I did
it you know I had a crappy childhood or
you know I felt that you know that it
was totally justified that guy dissed me
or she cheated on me or they all had
justifications and it was kind of
interesting to see the rationalizations
behind their arguments now from the
victims perspective that the perpetrator
is just pure evil
he did it because he enjoys suffering
the suffering of other people now there
are some you know Psychopaths or
Satanists that do that but they're very
small in number very tiny percentage of
the population most people in prison
that are killers are what they did it
for moralistic reasons you know he took
my parking spot so I you know we got in
a fight and then I killed him or you
know this guy slept with my girlfriend
and so I had to do something and defend
my honor and it one thing led to another
and Here I am in prison they almost all
have good moralistic reasoning so the
problem is not that we don't have enough
morality actually we have too much
morality too much moralizing about other
people that are harming us so you know
back to the free speech issue the moment
you say we're gonna create a category
called hate speech okay what goes in
that bin right well you know so it's so
I document in the in the opening page
that this really begins the United
States with in 1919 with the Schenck
versus the United States decision by the
United States Supreme Court to uphold
this conviction of this guy named shank
who was head of the Socialist Party in
Philadelphia in 1918 he was distributing
flyers to draft age men telling them
that the conscription is equivalent of
slavery because the 14th amendment
protects your right to bodily autonomy
and when the government says we're
drafting even in the military and we're
sending you to Europe this case for the
European Great War you know we now own
your body for the next four years okay
so this is what and so here's the famous
lines from Oliver Wendell Holmes Supreme
Court justice Oliver Wendell Holmes
Shanker
the United States that we're all
familiar with the most stringent
protection of free speech would not
protect a man in falsely shouting fire
in a theater in causing a panic the
question in every case is whether the
words used are used in such
circumstances and are of such a nature
as to create a clear and present danger
that they will bring about the
substantive evils that Congress has a
white right to prevent it is a question
of proximity and degree so clear and
present danger okay so we you you might
say okay so somebody incites a group to
riot and cause violence or something
like that so that's going to be called
hate speech but but but note what what
he considered at the time a clear and
present danger protestors of the draft
and their argument their argument is
pretty reasonable you know I mean you
can disagree with it and say no I think
in times of national crisis we have to
abolish set aside the Fourteenth
Amendment and can script young men into
the army and send them off toward to
potentially die that's our right to do
it to protect our nation but we should
be able to debate that but the moment
that happened in 1919 then category
creep or category expansion happened
where more and more things got put into
the bin of clear and present danger so
you're now doing something that I
consider to be a clear and present
danger a threat to our nation or state
or community or whatever so that
category just got bigger and bigger and
then so back to why liberals used to
defend free speech and now it's more
conservatives doing it and liberals in
favor of censorship begins with this
idea of something like in the 60s where
we began to become sensitive to the
words we use to describe other people
so the n-word you know describe African
Americans obviously the one we'd all
agree with yeah that's bad we shouldn't
do that okay what about the C word to
describe women are called Jews [ __ ] or
Vietnamese call them gooks or whatever
yeah yeah those are all hate speech so
the bin starts getting larger and larger
then all of a sudden you end up with
these lists of microaggressions I
reprint one in the book from UCLA the
University of California system and 2014
issued this long list of things you
can't say like where are you from or wow
you're good at math to someone who's not
Asian or wow you speak English so well
you know and these are now considered
hate speech the
they could trigger people's feelings of
being hurt and that is a form of clear
and present danger to the sort of
serenity of our community and all of a
sudden this category is now huge is
where are you from really on that list
it yeah it is yeah yeah my wife gets
this all the time because she's from
Germany and she speaks perfect English
he has no accent and people go wow I
can't believe you speak English so well
or well I can't believe you're not from
America or something like that and she
instead of being offended she just says
thank you I paid attention in school
[Applause]